there was some Andrew Tate updates there
has been a lot actually basically he was
he was arrested and detained for 30 days
they keep trying to appeal it and the
judge is like no you're staying they now
have the option to extend it to like 150
days or something of Kipping him yeah
wow they've seized all of his cars
they're gonna sell all of his supercars
to pay for the investigation and to go
to the victims yes sir we found out
there's been like an ongoing high level
deep investigation for nine months
including like the Romanian FBI
anti-terror unit serious I think what
happened with him is that he was paying
off people and local police but he flew
too close to the Sun and attracted fish
that were way too big for him to handle
and so the FBI is basically of Romania
set up this really elaborate
investigation including wiretapping they
have wire Taps of him saying crazy yeah
so he is a god Mega Meg [ __ ] I think
he's gonna go to jail for like 15 years
like he is done cooked cooked